[Musique]
nous avons une recherche qui reste de
qualité mais néanmoins nous décrochons
depuis que l'objectif de lisbonne 1 fixé
à 3% de la part du pib les dépenses que
nous devions faire en matière de
recherche la france est resté bloqué à 2
2 même si des efforts récents ont été
consentis on a sur le terrain constater
effectivement un très fort engagement
des équipes pour porter des projets
innovants mais dans cette phase de
recherches et effectivement on a aussi
constaté que parfois ce qui était
difficile c'était le passage à l'étape
supplémentaire au niveau supérieur du
développement industriel donc l'objectif
de cette mission a été d'essayer de
dégager en fait des réponses qu'on
pouvait apporter pour passer de ce qui a
pu être un rêve toxiques de la france
sans usine à une start up nation
industrielle ça vous concerne gérer
quand à la capacité que notre pays peut
avoir
ajustements se doter de d'éléments de
souveraineté sur tout les secteurs
innovants ont ce qu'on aura du mal à
rattraper ce qui est parti en revanche
dans tout ce qui relève de l'innovation
des années dans les années à venir
l'enjeu il est effectivement notre
souveraineté il est indispensable
d'avoir une vision de ce que serait la
france industrielle est ce qu on veut
toujours être un pays de production ou
est-ce qu'on veut être un pays de sous
traitance et de bâtir une stratégie
autour de cette vision ensuite c'est
d'orienter en fait les financements au
service de cette vision et de cette
stratégie et puis créer un écosystème y
compris de fonds privés qui vont être
susceptible d'accompagner les
entreprises industrielles pour faire
émerger de nouveaux champions en france
les accompagner sur le temps long avec
peut-être des retours sur investissement
qui n'obéissent pas aux règles actuelles
on peut trouver par exemple dans la lho
tech